one specific example for a demand-side
platform is the Google Display Network
the Google Display Network gdn is a
collection of over a million websites
apps videos and blogs that show AdWords
ads basically this million-plus sites
are using Google to help them offer
their page to monetize by providing
advertisers with online real estate to
advertise on the Google algorithm will
target the ads to the appropriate
audience by ensuring that the s are
relevant for the page content Edwards
will do this matching based on the
keywords you select and other factors
this will give you a much wider audience
than just being in search results with
gdn you have the opportunity to
fine-tune where you want your ads to be
seen beyond selecting an audience based
on keywords you can choose topics to
narrow your audience so for abarkment we
can choose to focus on dog related
websites or pick a specific site like
one that sells pet supplies or we can
block our eyes from certain sites that
aren't relevant to what we do like a
site that's dedicated to hating dogs and
loving cats we can even focus on people
who have been to our site before and
retarget them when they go to other
sites this is called remarketing and you
can find out more about that in the
instructor notes it's called the Display
Network because unlike Google search
where you can use only text ads here you
can display all type of formats like
text image interactive and video ads to
learn more about this check out the
instructor notes
so with AdWords beyond Google search we
can target the Display Network and
specifically for mobile you can capture
the mobile Google Display Network so if
you have a mobile website you can
advertise and with you know mobile text
ads or mobile image ads and capture
users who are browsing on different
sites on their mobile phone and they may
see one of your ads and decide to click
on it and go to your mobile site so
that's our regular mobile gdn or Google
Display Network and that's more to drive
users to your mobile site the other
opportunity you have is to to drive app
installs and we recommend setting up a
campaign
where you would target apps so your ad
would actually show in other apps and so
when a user is for example using an app
of maybe you you want to specify a
certain category in which you want to
target users so for example let's say I
like to travel a lot as a user I might
be on a lot of different travel apps
hotel apps you know flight apps whatever
it may be but it's maybe I also have a
dog at home and I need to make sure that
I have housing for my dog while I'm gone
well then as a you know dog Airbnb
business you can target users who are in
travel apps so that would be a type of
targeting you could set up find users
who are you know most likely to travel
and they're probably already using
travel apps and then I want to target my
ad to show when they're using one of
those travel apps and so you can think
about you know what's the best type of
targeting to capture that target
audience for you so one thing that I'm
really excited about is AdWords just
released a new type of a new campaign
type for display targeting specifically
for app promotion so it's called the
universal app campaign and it's one of
the easiest campaigns you can set up
which is why I really like it all you
need to do is link your app to the
campaign and say I want to drive users
to install my app and this is my target
cost per install price and then you
really just type up four different lines
that could be cycled through for the ad
creative and then AdWords does the rest
they create the ad formats and then they
then AdWords will determine all of the
targeting the great thing about a
universal app campaign is that it
targets all the different platforms that
Google can offer so that would include
Google search and Google Play but also
the Google Display Network like we were
talking about it would target all
categories for apps so
can have a nap in-app ads and then it
also targets YouTube now I haven't
talked about YouTube yet but let's say
you have a YouTube video promoting your
business so you can drop that video in
this campaign and it will also start
targeting users on YouTube so the great
thing is it covers all the different
bases it's a really easy setup and it
just drives downloads at your target
cost per install so um you know it's
it's a campaign that is easy to set up
and it knows what you want ideally it's
gonna deliver that within a couple weeks
of testing